un groupe est prêt à intervenir ils
s'appellent le raid le raid c'est un
nouveau service de police un service
d'élite 77 hommes qui ont suivi un
entraînement très poussée alors comme il
a été créé récemment c'est la première
fois qu'il va intervenir sur une prise
d'otage recherche assistance
intervention dissuasion le raid en place
autour du palais de justice de nantes
est la dernière née des cellules
d'intervention spécialisée dans les
prises d'otages ou les affaires de
terrorisme
son patron robert broussard ancien
préfet de corse pierre joxe le ministre
de l'intérieur en a fait revenir au
printemps dernier avec son adjoint
hantsch mancini pour mettre en place et
dirigé cette équipe de super flic
les voici à l'entraînement soixante dix
sept hommes retenus sur plus de 1000
candidats ils ont suivi une formation
extrêmement poussé opération surprise en
hélicoptère tir de précision combat
rapproché
l'équivalent dans la peau liste du gign
de la gendarmerie
cette prise d'otage de nantes constitue
le baptême opérationnelle du raid avec
un bon point déjà les hommes de
broussard et mancini sont arrivés sur
place très rapidement alors pourront-ils
intervenir sans mettre la vie des otages
en danger la salle d'audience où ils se
trouvent et isolé à l'intérieur du
palais de justice
il est difficile de savoir ce qui se
passe derrière cette porte aucune
fenêtre ne permet de suivre les
mouvements des preneurs d'otages
si les hommes du raid veulent intervenir
ils devront donc compter sur leur
fatigue ou une erreur de leur part